une rue des passants des fenêtres
que tu vois c'est des menaces
potentielles
alors tu peux
[Musique]
j services de cloud ou pas pas le temps
ouais les mecs avec qui j'ai fait
[Musique]
moi je suis à rendre à la france le pas
le mois mais toi tu fous là
je suis là c'est tout
vous avez vu des femmes dans l'armée
française moi j'ai vu des soldats vous
êtes un soldat mais mon commandant santé
ou deux doigts du cul en fait moi ce
parterre au revoir on a tous des
problèmes mais quand tu arrives au
régiment tu les laisses derrière toi est
ce que tu sais pourquoi on porte en
uniforme pour uniformiser justement donc
je veux pas savoir ce qu'il ya dans ta
tête je veux pas savoir ce qui se passe
chez toi on fout de savoir combien tu as
à mettre ko je sais pourquoi je suis un
matin j'ai pris temps
je ne seront pas du tout juste un mec
déterminé peut anéantir l'humanité en
deux secondes
et qui pour la radio
[Musique]
c'est tout
non je suis prêt